1, 3, minus 5 and 8.
This is just a row of four numbers
and this can be represented in different ways.
We can write it as an array of numbers horizontally like this
or we can write it as an array of numbers vertically like this.
The first part as you can see has one row and four columns
and the second part has four rows and one column.
There's another way in which we can write the four numbers.
The first two numbers in the first row
and the last two numbers in the second row.
All these three things you see here are called matrices.
Each of these is a Matrix.
Just an arrangement of rows and columns.
But how do we properly define it?
We can say that a matrix is a rectangular arrangement.
But a rectangular arrangement of what?
It can be anything.
Numbers, letters or the characters. Anything.
A Matrix is made up of rows and column.
The first Matrix has one row and four columns.
The second one has four rows and one column.
And what about the third one?
It has two rows and 2 columns.
So a matrix is just a rectangular arrangement of rows and columns
But there is one important condition we need to keep in mind.
Each row needs to have equal number of elements.
For instance in the second Matrix,
each row has one element.
And in the third matrix each row has two elements.
And each column also needs to have equal number of elements.
In the first Matrix each column has one element,
the second Matrix has just one column so it doesn't matter
and in the third one each column has two elements.
So a matrix is a
rectangular arrangement of rows and columns
in which each row has equal number of elements
and each column as well has equal number of elements.
So is this a Matrix?
Elements 'a' and 'b' in the first row
and elements 'c' and 'd' in the second.
It is a rectangular arrangement.
Each row has two elements
and each column has two elements.
It is a Matrix!
And these three are also Matrices.
Okay, what about this one with three elements?
Is it a matrix?
The first row has two elements
but the second one has just has one element.
So it is not a matrix.
What about this one with five elements?
The number of elements in each of the columns
is not the same.
It's 2, 1 and 2 and this as well is not a matrix.
So this is the definition.
A rectangular arrangement of rows and columns in
which each row should have equal number of elements
and each column as well.
should have equal number of elements.